Speaker 1: Now, I talked about Florida
for a moment, and I got to talk about
something even more disturbing
Down here in the state of Florida
on Monday, a Republican state legislator here
in Florida by the name of Webster Barnaby
during a hearing on a transgender bathroom
bill that will make it a criminal offense
for a transgender individual to use the
bathroom of the gender that they identify as.
Mr. Barnaby went on a bigoted, disgusting
tirade against transgender people. So we
have the clip of it. Here he is again. This man
is Webster Barnaby. He is a Republican state
representative here in Florida. Take a look.
Speaker 2: I'm looking at society today and
it's like I'm watching an X-Men movie with
people that when you watch the X-Men movies
for Marvel Comics. It's like we have mutants
living among us on planet Earth. And, you know,
some people don't like that, but that's a fact.
We have people that live among us today on planet
Earth. That. Are happy to display themselves.
As if they were mutants from another planet.
This is the planet Earth where God
created men, male and women, female.
I'm a proud Christian conservative
Republican. I'm not on the fence.
Not on the fence. There is so much darkness in
our world today. So much evil in our world today.
And so many people who are afraid to address
the evil, the dysphoria, the dysfunction.
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction. The Lord rebuke you,
Satan and all of your demons and all of
your imps will come parade before us.
That's right. I called you Daemons
and Imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this world.
Speaker 1: Webster Barnaby, Republican
representative here in the state
of Florida. The words that he used.
Like you're from another planet, You're a mutant,
you're a demon, you're an imp. All of those words
are meant to dehumanize other people. He is
dehumanizing, taking away their very personhood.
Of transgender individuals here in the state of
Florida. Now, of course, he issued an apology. Oh,
he's sorry that he said it. No, you're not.
You're absolutely not sorry that you said
it. You're sorry that there's backlash
on it. You meant every word you said.
You wouldn't have done that. You wouldn't have
doubled down on it. You wouldn't have repeated
yourself over and over if you didn't mean it. And
I got to bring up, of course, too, as a X-Men fan.
His invocation of the X-Men there
actually proves that he doesn't know.
The whole point of X-Men is that these
individuals are are treated differently.
They are looked down upon by society because they
are different, because they were born different.
And they are the subject of of prejudices.
They are the subject of laws restricting
their very existence. All of that takes place in
the X-Men comics. And this guy, Webster Barnaby,
doesn't have the wherewithal to understand
that he's the bad guy in the X-Men comics.
He's Reverend Stryker. And
he doesn't even. Realize it.
But that's who he is. Sorry, it's not Reverend
Stryker, but he hates these people because of who
they are. And he's pushing like every other
Republican in the state. This bill to ban
transgender people from using public restrooms.
Of course, again, completely ignoring the irony.
Of saying, guess what? We're going
back to the days of segregation.
These certain people who look a certain
way can't use the same bathroom. Have you
thought about that, folks? Have you actually sat
down and realized that we're heading back into
the days of segregation? We're not moving past
it. We're not learning from our past mistakes.
And Mr. Barnaby. Granted, he was born
and raised in England. He only moved to
the United States in 1991. So even though
he was born in 1959, he didn't experience
the segregation that was taking place here
in the United States at the time. I'm sure
as a naturalized citizen, he knows about it.
He had to have studied it. He is aware of what
this country once was, and now he's part of
the group trying to take us back to that.
For the record, I've looked and looked and
looked. I cannot find a single instance
where a transgender person has been accused
of assaulting someone in a public restroom.
Do you know why? Because they're going in there
to use the bathroom. Right. You're out and about.
You're shopping. Hey, I need to go relieve
myself. You go in there, you do your business,
you wash your hands and you leave. That's it.
That's it. And we're saying that that is too
much that is too much of a privilege to extend to
transgender people. They're just trying to exist.
They're not out there breaking laws down
out there doing anything wrong. They're
not coming after us. They're not trying to
indoctrinate us. They just want to live.
And here in Florida and across the
country, in red states, we're saying,
no, your existence is offensive
to me, so I want to oppress you.
We have seen this before, not just in
American history, but in world history.
And it never ends well for that group that is
being oppressed. But that oppression is alive
and well here in the state of Florida,
thanks to people like Webster, Barnaby,
Barnaby Webster or Webster Barnaby. Yeah, I had
it right. Anyway, we've got to take another break.
I'm Farah Cousins of David Pakman. You're watching
The David Pakman Show. We'll be right back.